Це шукачі скарбів. Їх у Німеччині стає дедалі більше.
Археологи б'ють на сполох.
Маріон Брюґлер керує розкопками римського поховання,
якому 2000 років.  Побоюючись нелегалів із металошукачами,
вчена та її команда проводять розкопки таємно, коли це можливо.
Жінка каже, що шукачі скарбів абсолютно непередбачувані
й можуть несподівано з'явитися на місці розкопок серед ночі.
- Коли  копачів охоплює лихоманка і вони риють глибше і глибше,
бо з-під землі ще йде сигнал, і коли знахідка, що була тут схована,
втрачається, то, можливо, втрачається найважливіший датований предмет
або такий, що дозволяє розкрити таємницю розкопки.
Через таке варварство науковці назавжди втрачають
цінні артефакти. Збиток, заподіяний нелегальними шукачами скарбів,
на думку поліції, сягає мільйонів євро.
Полювання за скарбами з металошукачами
стало ледь не національним видом спорту.
Багато шукачів скарбів одягнені в камуфляж,
оснащені найкращою технікою. Це стало великим захопленням, бо приносить велику здобич.
- Коли починаєш займатися цим хобі,
маєш певне уявлення про це, аж раптом отримуєш
сигнал металошукача і, можливо, там справді щось цікаве, і ти думаєш: це воно!
Щороку шукачі скарбів організовують для себе чемпіонат.
У землю закопують металеві монети й кілька золотих.
Той, хто знайде найбільшу кількість і найдорожчі монети,
стає чемпіоном Німеччини.
- Перший сигнал! Золото! Золото!
Перший сигнал, перша монета, головна знахідка, золота монета.
Усього лише гра для дорослих?
Але не для археологині Маріон Брюґлер.
Для неї чемпіонат шукачів скарбів -
можливість із ними поспілкуватися й пояснити,
скільки шкоди для науки завдає нелегальне копання.
- Мій найгірший досвід - це коли ми досліджували під час розкопок стародавні поховання,
а вночі хтось пройшовся з вилами та повикопував
усе, що можна було викопати.
Було видно сліди від вил і, звичайно, в такому разі багато що втрачається.
Археолог Петер Генріх з міста Кобленц
також бореться проти нелегальних розкопок.
- Так це має виглядати: розкладаєте знахідки
в пакетики з номером та запискою.
Чудово.  Отже, тут всі римські монети 1-го століття нашої ери, мабуть...
Багато хто викидає таке в смітник.
А тут знахідка отримує номер, оцінку та реєструється.
Так це має відбуватися!
Частина вільних шукачів скарбів
залюбки співпрацюють з археологами.
Інші почуваються, наче під наглядом.
Копачі артефактів хочуть пригод, як  Аксель Тіль із Крахта.
Він керує інтернет-порталом під назвою "Німецький союз шукачів скарбів".
- Це товариство, через яке ми намагаємося роз'яснювати громадськості,
що ми не робимо чогось забороненого.
Оскільки археологи часто припускають, що
для пошуку скарбів потрібна ліцензія  і люди, які її не мають, є якимись грабіжниками. Це невірно!
Відносини між археологами та вільними шукачами скарбів дуже напружені.
Адже деякі вільні копачі захоплюються пошуками зброї, бомб чи амуніції.
Це не лише небезпечно, а й заборонено,
так само як і нелегальні розкопки стародавніх поховань.